we need the whole team here in two hours  i'm very sorry  in my culture dead  it's not the end it's my  way stepping off point  you reach out with both hands and bust  in sekhmet  they lead you into the green world where  you can run forever  that sounds very peaceful  my father thought so  i am not my father t'challa  task force will decide who brings in  barnes  don't bother miss romanov  i'll kill him myself  [Music]  yeah you all right uh yeah thanks i  i got lucky  i know how much barnes means to you i  really do  stay home you only make this worse  for all of us please are you saying  you'll arrest me  no someone will  if you interfere that's how it works now  if he's this far gone that  i should be the one to bring him in why  because i'm the one least likely to die  trying  you